stellen wir uns vor da kommt einer und
sagt ich kenne die vergangenheit besser
als ihr darum sich besser in die zukunft
als ihr wir würden denken ein
weltfremder schöngeist nicht der
diskussion wert doch dann erfahren wir
er ist einer der einflussreichsten
historiker der welt und von wegen
weltfremd die weltwirtschaft elite hin
ihm eben hier am world economic forum in
davos an den lippen und fragte ihn nach
lösungen zu sehr aktuellen problemen
dieser welt dann würden wir sagen und
tun ist auch nicht vergessen herzlich
willkommen in der sternstunde
philosophie
vielen dank dass man ein großes
vergnügen hier zu sein bei ihnen auch
wenig wenn ich ein bisschen müde denn
alles auf deutsch zu machen und das okay
bei dir ist bleibe ich auf englisch vor
wir freuen uns sehr dass sie hier sind
die globale wirtschafts elite hat ihnen
zugehört wie in einem gut ich habe das
selber beobachtet hier was sieht ein
historiker was andere nicht sehen
sie haben churchill zitiert als sie
sagten je mehr man in die vergangenheit
schaut desto weiter sieht man in die
zukunft
ich finde das stimmt und die kenntnis
der geschichte ist ein vorteil wenn man
über die gegenwart und die zukunft
nachdenkt oder vielleicht sollte ich
sagen über die zukunft in der mehrzahl
denn es geht nicht nur ein zukunft ein
teil dessen was man lernt beim studium
der geschichte ist eben genau die
vielfalt der möglichen ergebnisse in
jedem gegebenen augenblick wir
historiker unterscheiden uns von den
ökonomen oder den
politikwissenschaftlern wir haben keine
mathematischen modelle und wir erheben
nicht den anspruch die zukunft
vorhersagen zu können
wir haben jedoch analogie wir können
sagen ereignisse leicht ereignis b und
vielleicht auch ereignis c oder
staatsmann a gleich staatsmann b oder c
anhand solcher analogien können wir
gewisse lehren aus der vergangenheit
ein großer britischer geschichte des
namens kalin wird sagte die historiker
studieren die vergangenheit um das
denken und die erfahrungen der
vergangenheit zurück kunst um ihr und
indem sie parallelen zwischen dem denken
der vergangenheit und dem unsrigen
ziehen unsere eigene zeit und die
zukunft besser zu verstehen
ich finde das ist genau die aufgabe der
historiker aber kann man sich zurück in
ein denken in einen bauern 17 89 bei der
französischen revolution
wenn man das denken der vergangenheit
rekonstruieren kann von jeder
historischen figur ob könig oder bauer
dann gewiss man kann es immer in
abhängigkeit dessen was überdauert hat
die meisten menschen haben im lauf der
geschichte freilich kein zeugnis ihres
lebens hinterlassen
die mehrzahl der menschen die hier auf
erden lebten sie sind ohne zahl und den
meisten von ihnen haben wir keinen
zugang denn sie haben kein zeugnis von
ihrem leben hinterlassen wir historiker
können nur jene studieren die in
schriftlichen oder sonst in den
zeugnissen weiterleben
unsere aufgabe ist es deren erfahrungen
aus den spuren die sie hinterlassen
haben zu rekonstruieren
diese imaginativen schritte sind zentral
für das was die historiker versuchen zu
tun
man kann sehr große sprünge in der zeit
zurück machen so bei zeugnisse vorhanden
sind
das heißt sie sehen die menschheit als
ein großes experiment und wir sind nicht
so verschieden von den akteuren früher
jahrtausende sogar in einer hinsicht
sind wir gleich seit beginn der
geschichte haben wir uns ja nicht
dramatisch weiterentwickelt
aber wir sind doch auch sehr anders und
was die geschichte dabei spannend macht
ist dass wir zeigen können wie anders
das leben früher war selbst in der
jüngeren vergangenheit
etwa im neunzehnten jahrhundert passt
unser leben ist völlig anders als das
unserer großeltern
sie haben sich und mit gutem grund
vielmehr vor dem tod geführt
ihr leben war vielmehr durch krankheiten
gefährdet in diesem sinne gehört es zur
aufgabe der historiker zu zeigen was
allgemein gültig ist für die menschliche
existenz
liebe all die gefühlslagen die tugenden
und die laster die dinge die sich durch
die ganze literatur ziehen und die wir
sogar in homers erzählungen finden aber
die historiker müssen auch zeigen wie
anders es zeit war ein mensch zu sein
es ist wichtig dass wir verstehen dass
die vergangenheit gewissermaßen ein
anderer planet war und dass unsere
vorfahren in einer völlig anderen welt
lebten als wir von ihnen in einem ihrer
bücher habe ich gelernt die akteure der
früheren geschichte waren fast alles
junge männer die bevölkerung war zu
allen zeiten überwiegend jung und zwar
durch alle gesellschaftlichen schichten
hindurch
wir fallen diesbezüglich ziemlich aus
dem rahmen weil heute so viele über das
alter von 30 hinaus leben
man braucht nicht weit zurück zu gehen
um in den meisten gegenden der welt eine
lebenserwartung von etwa 30 jahren zu
finden
natürlich wurden zu allen zeiten auch
einige menschen sehr alt darum sind
unsere geschichtsbücher voll von
bärtigen männern diejenigen die 65 jahre
und älter wurden lebten lange genug um
ihren ruf als große denker zu begründen
doch die meisten menschen aller
schichten lebten nicht lange und die
meisten großen errungenschaften wurden
von sehr jungen menschen vollbracht
männern und frauen
freilich muss gesagt werden vor allem
von männern
früher spielten die frauen in den
meisten gesellschaften eine deutlich
untergeordnete rolle
und die meisten historischen zeugnisse
widerspiegeln die erfahrungen von
männern
so ist die geschichte zwangsläufig
sexistisch hinsichtlich ihrer figuren
weil die frauen und historischen
zeugnissen viel weniger vorkommen also
geschichte ist eine methode bei der man
lernt zukünfte zu skizzieren zu
vergleichen mit der name darum sieht man
auch in die zukunft irgendwo in einem
interview haben sie sogar gesagt ich
kann das vielleicht besser als die
politologen die soziologen und die
ökonomen ich glaube darum sind die leute
in ihre veranstaltungen hier in davos
auch geströmt aber sie machen das ja mit
leidenschaft schon seit sehr jung und es
gibt die große geschichte der menschheit
und dann haben wir unsere kleinen
einzelgeschichten darf ich ihre story
wie sie historiker wurden so
zusammenfassen mangelndes rugby talent
und die liebe zu friedrich schiller
haben aus ihnen einen star restoring
große vereinfachung sie sagen ein
bisschen ich kam 1964 in glasgow zur
welt und bin in schottland aufgewachsen
und ich bin durch und durch pro jahr
mein vater war arzt und meine mutter
lehrerin sie konnten beide als erste
ihrer familien studieren unser ziel war
gesellschaftliche anerkennung lang
bildung die größte ambition meines
vaters war dass sie nach box forschen
er hätte auch gern gesehen wenn ich für
schottland rugby gespielt hätte aber für
rugby hatte ich zu wenig talent und
wohlig diesen sport liebe und es kam
dass ich mich für geschichte begeisterte
mich interessierten zwar viele dinge in
der schule
ich liebte auch mathematik doch damit
haben wir eine erleuchtung ein
augenblick der wahrheit in einer
bibliothek in glasgow ich musste einen
aufsatz über den dreißigjährigen krieg
schreiben für das hiesige publikum wohl
ein bekanntes thema so ging ich zu jener
bibliothek auf der suche nach einem buch
um mich einzulesen
doch da fanden sich etwa 30 bücher zum
30 jährigen
und eines davon war friedrich schillers
geschichte ich nahm es und in diesem
augenblick wusste ich dass ich
historiker werden würde
ich war so überwältigt dass es so viele
bücher über dieses eine ereignis
es war anders als sagen wir die stücke
von shakespeare zu studieren da gibt es
nur einen heinrich den fünften und hier
gab es so viele bücher über diesen
dreißigjährigen krieg die bis auf die
zeit von schiller zurückreichten also
sie haben erkannt die geschichte wie sie
passiert ist kann man mit ganz
verschiedenen brillen ansehen das hat
sie fasziniert aber gibt es dann eine
richtige version also kann man wahrheit
erkennen
als historiker ich glaube wir sollten
uns nicht darauf versteifen historiker
versuchen unter anderem wie leo pranke
sagte die geschichte der vergangenheit
so zu erzählen wie es eigentlich gewesen
und das kann man wohl auf englisch
übersetzen mit
wir können die vergangenheit nicht
lückenlos rekonstruieren
nicht einmal das gestern können wir in
unserem eigenen leben ganz
rekonstruieren weil wir viele details
schon vergessen haben
das scheint mir zentral zu sein für die
menschliche existenz
wir behalten nicht jede sekunde unseres
lebens im kopf wie auf einer festplatte
der historiker bemüht sich daher um die
essentielle wahrheit über die
vergangenheit anhand der erhalten
gebliebenen zeugnisse es gibt jedoch ein
ziel und das ist ganz gewiss mein ziel
wenn ich ein geschichtsbuch schreibe
nämlich so nahe wie möglich
heranzukommen um meinen lesern die
erfahrung der geschichte bieten zu
können
es wird nie vollkommen sein das ist
unmöglich stellen sie sich eine
vollkommene biografie vor sie wäre so
lang wie das leben des porträtierten
selbst widersprochen mit seinem satz
geschichte ist die lüge auf die man sich
geeinigt hat wollte er war ein witziger
mensch und bekannt für seine flotten
sprüche
doch ich finde dass man der geschichts
disziplinen gewalt antut wenn man sie
nur als einen haufen lügen abtut
lügen können ein unterhaltsames element
in der geschichtsschreibung sein wenn
man zum beispiel aus biografien
berühmter männer mögen heraus pflücken
kann
da wimmelt es meist von lüge und es ist
faszinierend anhand weiterer dokumente
solche lügengebilde zu zerzausen bei
historischen aufzeichnungen hat man ja
oft die möglichkeit quervergleiche zu
machen
man kann besonders als moderner
historiker wie ich beweise aus
verschiedenen quellen finden
es gibt meistens mehrere zeugen eines
bestimmten ereignisses
es gibt einander widersprechende
aussagen und in dieser hinsicht arbeitet
man ein wenig wie ein anwalt in dem man
aus verschiedenen beweisstücken etwas
zusammensetzt das der wahrheit nahe
kommt ich fürchte also dass ich wollte
nicht zustimmen kann
die geschichte ist besser als das liegt
die leidenschaft und die freude und
befriedigung die man in diesem beruf
finden kann auch darin wie ein kommissar
zu den quellen zu gehen
die bibliotheken machen sie das noch
selber oder schicken sie 100 studenten
aus nein ich schicke nicht hunderte von
studenten die archive ich habe einen
forschungsassistenten der mir beim
material sammeln hilft zwischen
lehrtätigkeit und interviews mit
gentleman wie ihnen bin ich beschäftigt
das sammeln von material in archiven
muss sich ja nicht unbedingt selbst
machen wenn ich auch anders als material
kommen aus der großen menge an
dokumenten versuche ich eine geschichte
zusammenzufügen
es ist eine außerordentlich
befriedigende arbeit
ich muss es wohl aus liebe tun aber ich
glaube nicht dass es genau dasselbe ist
wie ein gerichtsverfahren
[Musik]
anders als in einem prozess stellte
historiker menschen nicht in den
zeugenstand
und er will sie auch nicht wie ein
anwalt anklagen oder verteidigen
der historiker versucht zu verstehen
verstehen diese idee des verstehens
welche dem deutschen historismus
zugrunde liegt ist unser eigentliches
anliegen
die leute können sich aber auch nicht
mehr wehren wenn sie sagen napoleon
wollte dies alexander der große wollte
dass er hat keine gegenrede mehr macht
das nicht ein bisschen einfach für den
historiker kann nicht sagen was er will
nein der historiker ist in seinem tun
sehr eingeschränkt im gegensatz zum
romancier er kann nicht einfach
behaupten dass jemand etwas gesagt hat
das ist eine strenge regeln an die ich
gebunden wenn man geschichte schreibt
hat man so hübsche konstruktion zu
vermeiden wie es muss wohl so und so
gewesen sein oder er muss wohl gefühlt
haben oder sie muss wohl gedacht haben
das dürfen wir nicht sagen denn wir
wissen es nicht
das einzige was wir tun können ist worte
zu zitieren die aufgezeichnet wurden
nachdem oder bald nachdem sie jemand
gesagt hatte auch tagebücher sind eine
gute quelle briefe
ein zeitalter der presse finden wir
relativ gute aufzeichnungen dessen was
menschen gesagt haben
aber erfinden darf man nichts das ist
eine wichtige regel also ich staune dass
der harvard-professor vergessen nur
einen assistenten aus schickt aber der
chefkoch tier halt selber das gar nicht
wiederum ich möchte betonen dass es
letztlich eine einsame beschäftigung ist
historiker arbeiten nicht wie
naturwissenschaftler inmitten großer
teams im labor
sie haben nicht scharen von
forschungsassistenten wie einige meiner
haut kollegen in anderen favoriten
wir sind in gewisser weise handwerker
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen als
historiker ein atelier zu haben mein
laden ist sehr klein und mein assistent
und ich arbeiten seit über zehn jahren
sehr eng zusammen gelegentlich habe ich
studenten diene dies und das
zusammentragen auch damit sie die praxis
kennenlernen aber im wesentlichen ist es
eine sache zwischen den schwellen und
wenn sie sagen
by the way i are pretty busy dann kann
ich dem publikum bestätigen dass er sehr
ein gefragter mann ist schwierig zu
greifen auch für eine stunde aber uns
freut das enorm wie gesagt dass das
gelungen ist weil sie sind gefragt
haffter ganzen welt im quasi auch als
berater und irgendwo habe ich gelesen
sie scheuen sich auch nicht davor zu
sagen aus meinem beruf geschichte mache
ich ein geschäft und sie haben
geschrieben das hätten sie gelernt dass
das ok und gut ist von der rothschild
banker familie als sie über die road
schied geforscht haben woran ich bin
gewiss kein rothschild ob schon ich eine
geschichte der rothschild familie und
ihrer bank mal geschrieben habe ich habe
mich immer für wirtschaftsgeschichte
interessiert insbesondere für die
geschichte des finanzwesens der banken
und finanzinstitute als ich an einem
anderen projekt arbeitete der biografie
von siegmund warburg erstaunte mich dass
er als sogenannter handelsbank hier auch
ein gefragter berater
er war nicht in großem stil in
transaktion involviert seine bank war
eher klein gemessen an den
geschäftszahlen vergleichbar mit mancher
schweizer privatbank warburg war
hauptsächlich als berater von
unternehmungen und regierungen tätig und
als ich dieses buch schrieb kam mir der
gedanke dass es eigentlich nicht schaden
würde wenn ich selbst ein wenig in die
beratung einsteigen würde
denn mit den erkenntnissen aus der
geschichte die ich in 25 30 jahren
gesammelt hatte kann ich zu vielen
themen die eine oder andere sichtweise
und ge einbringen
eine der großen herausforderungen für
jeden entscheidungsträger ist heute dass
es diese definierten speicher gibt den
speicher angeschriebene wirtschaft und
den speicher angeschrieben mit
nationaler sicherheit oder mit
außenpolitik
das sind sehr unterschiedliche
disziplinen
die einen wissen viel zu dieser die
anderen viel zur anderen disziplin der
historiker aber ist in der lage beides
zusammen zu sehen
ich betrachte wirtschaftliche und
politische angelegenheiten im
zusammenhang denn sie sind in der tat
und rennen war
die ereignisse der letzten sieben jahre
mit der finanzkrise sind kaum zu
verstehen wenn man nichts von wirtschaft
versteht so oft war es die politik die
dominierte besonders in der krise der
eurozone
so habe ich in den vergangenen vier
jahren im privatsektor eine
beratungstätigkeit entwickelt mit hilfe
von erkenntnissen aus der geschichte das
läuft ganz gut und darum wollte das
weltwirtschaftsforum hier sie auch in
davos haben um zu den
wirtschaftskapitänen dieser welt zu
sprechen und ein großes thema in diesem
jahr dass die politik überschattet in
europa ist die flüchtlingskrise aus der
perspektive eines historikers könnte man
nicht sagen so warb flüchtlingskrise das
hat es schon gegeben menschen sind auch
früher in großen massen herumgezogen das
muss uns nicht besonders aufregend
bedeutet als diese krise die medien zu
beherrschen begann darf
ich als erstes an andere
flüchtlingskrise nan andere perioden der
verschiebung großer bevölkerungsteile in
der europäischen geschichte
allein in der deutschen geschichte gab
es manche große migrationsbewegung sogar
in den vergangenen 100 jahren ein großer
migrations schub entstand nach dem fall
der berliner mauer als auf deutsch nach
westdeutschland zogen das ist noch in
frischer erinnerung etwas früher gab es
eine große einwanderung nach deutschland
vor allem aus der türkei
die gastarbeiter noch früher am ende des
zweiten weltkriegs geschah eine große
umsiedlung von ethnischen deutschen aus
osteuropa nach deutschland
der hat bene domes es gab riesige
völkerwanderungen im laufe der
geschichte
und genauso in prähistorischer zeit vor
der geschriebenen geschichte
da gab es besonders große bewegungen die
für die gestaltung unserer welt von
entscheidender bedeutung waren
es ist also nicht so dass die heutigen
migration neu wäre aufgabe des
historikers ist es zu fragen ob sie
vergleichsweise groß oder klein sei in
der tat ist es eine kleine
wanderbewegung verglichen mit derjenigen
innerhalb des nahen ostens in der türkei
leben viel mehr flüchtlinge als in
deutschland
wenn man sich aber fragt was das im
kontext der modernen europäischen
geschichte bedeutet stehen einige dinge
hervor
das erste ist ein großes
integrationsproblem für migranten
besonders für asylsuchende auf dem
nordeuropäischen arbeitsmarkt das wissen
wir von der viel kleineren migration der
90er jahre mit ihrem ernüchternden
ergebnisse in bezug auf die integration
nehmen wir nur deutschland oder schweden
mit ihrer unverhältnismäßig großen zahl
an asylsuchenden in den 90er jahren von
bosnien aber auch von weiter weg von
somalia bedenken sie ich bin mit einer
frau verheiratet die geflüchtet ist
meine frau aline hirsi ali er suchte in
den niederlanden um asyl
sie stammt aus somalia
ich verfüge also über einige kenntnisse
in dieser geschichte zusammen mit dir
gehören sie zu den leuten die sehr klar
warnen dass man ein kritisches auge
werfen muss auf alles was mit radikalen
islam zu tun das ist der zweite punkt
der erste war schon bevor diese neu ist
der migrationswelle entstand tat sich
das nördliche europa bei der integration
von asylsuchenden in wirtschaft und
gesellschaft schwer
der zweite punkt ist dass so viele
asylsuchende aus islamischen ländern
kamen und einen kulturellen konflikt
auslöst
vielleicht sagen sie zwei drei sätze für
ihre frau ist bekannt und in den news
auch oft gewesen damals als die politik
gemacht hat in europa jetzt sind sie
beide in amerika zwei drei sätze über
das schicksal das sie zusammengebracht
hat meine frau ist eine außergewöhnliche
person und so schön wie brillant und
musik sie gehörte der kleinen zahl von
flüchtlingen aus der früheren periode
deren flucht in den westen zu einer
erfolgsgeschichte wurde
sie sprach anfangs kein holländisch
schrubbte fabrik böden
sie schaffte es an die universität von
leiden eine der größten europas und
promovierte in politologie sie ging in
die politik wurde ins holländische
parlament gewählt nicht viele der
neuankömmlinge jener zeit können einen
vergleichbaren erfolg aufweisen
doch in dem augenblick als ayaan hirsi
ali begannen sich öffentlich gegen den
radikalen islam zu stellen
im zusammenhang mit dem elften september
und sozialen problemen die den
niederlanden zu beginn der grossen
migrationsbewegungen herrschte wurde sie
heftig angegriffen und erhielt
morddrohungen von islamisten ihr kollege
der filmemacher theo van gogh wurde in
amsterdam auf offener straße ermordet
von einem dschihadisten der ihr drohte
als nächste dran zu
das hat ihr leben tiefgreifend verändert
in der zwischenzeit haben sich allianz
vorhersagen längst bewahrheitet ihre
beharrliche mahnung bei den problemen
mit dem gewaltsamen extremismus die
rolle des islam nicht zu ignorieren hat
allmählich an boden gewonnen und wird
nicht mehr einfach bestritten
das mantra der islam sei eine religion
des friedens wird man immer seltener
denn im zeitalter des islamischen
staates wird es immer schwieriger
dies mit gutem gewissen zu behaupten ich
finde das ist eine unerhört wichtige
geschichte und sie wird personifiziert
durch eier ins lebensgeschichte denken
das ja immer ein historiker war war kein
blatt vor den mund genommen hat und wenn
wir diese sendungen unser gespräch ein
bisschen unter dem titel stellen der
westen am abgrund sind sie einer der
davor gewarnt hat und sagt der westen
ist ein gutes modell das heute nicht
über den abgrund hinaus gehen also da
waren sie immer schon entschieden für
die westlichen werte hat diese begegnung
dann die große liebe die heirat mit
ihrer frau hirsi ali ihre sicht noch
radikalisiert ich glaube nicht dass dies
mit radikalisierung zu tun hat vielmehr
mit erkenntnis wenn man wie ich in eine
freie gesellschaft hinein geboren wurde
und aufwuchs mit den regeln des gesetzes
mit freiheit mit der gleichwertigkeit
der geschlechter wenn man aufwuchs in
der gewissheit dass man sagen schreiben
und denken kann was man will und sich
treffen kann mit wem man will wenn man
in dieser gewissheit aufgewachsen ist
ist es sehr leicht dies alles als
gegeben anzusehen
ich habe vor dem ende des kalten krieges
gesehen wie eine unfreie gesellschaft
aussieht als ich eine zeitlang in
ostdeutschland und der sowjetunion
lebten
da bekam ich eine ahnung was freiheit
bedeutet in somalia in den späten 60er
jahren als mädchen geboren zu werden und
in einer muslimischen familie
aufzuwachsen
das bedeutete unfreiheit zu erfahren in
einem ausmaß dass ich mir nicht leicht
vorstellen konnte in diesem sinne haben
mich allianz entdeckung der freiheit im
westen ihre hochachtung vor den werten
der aufklärung in meiner auffassung
bestätigt dass dies die wichtigsten
errungenschaften der westlichen
zivilisation sind wir müssen sie hegen
und pflegen und nicht erlauben dass sie
infolge eines gutgläubigen relativismus
preisgegeben werden das ist auch die
kernaussage in meinem buch civilization
die westliche kultur war sehr
erfolgreich
etwa ab 1500 über das genaue datum lässt
sich streiten war es der westen das
heißt europa und länder wo sich europäer
niederließen wo die menschen reicher
gesünder und kulturell politisch und
militärisch dominant wurden wir haben
die geschichte gemacht
ich springe gerne im unbedingt mit ihnen
in die vergangenheit zurück nur noch
eine frage zur gegenwart es gibt
natürlich viele die sagen
unter den muslimen ist es nur eine
kleine radikale minderheit die diesen
gewalttätigen ideen anhängt und vor ein
paar wochen hatte ich in dieser sendung
als gast joschka fischer den früheren
deutschen außenminister
und er hat gesagt es wäre eben richtig
wenn europa die muslime kommen lässt
damit sie hier einen aufgeklärten islam
entwickeln können wo sonst sagt er geht
nirgends sonst
europa wäre der ort wo der islam seine
aufklärung durch laufen könnte hier ist
nun gut erhofft
und dies wäre ja auch die wünsch beste
entwicklung
das jüngste buch meiner frau fertig
informiert euch ist ein aufruf seiner
islamischen reformation die zu einer
islamischen aufklärung führen sollte sie
argumentiert das christentum und
judentum diesen prozess durchlaufen
dass sie die trennung von kirche und
staat vollzogen und ein maß an toleranz
errungen haben dass es dem einzelnen
auch möglich macht auszutreten ohne mit
dem tode bestraft zu werden
ist aus dem islam auszutreten bedeutet
auch heute noch die todesstrafe zu
gewärtigen
das ist nicht etwa der standpunkt einer
minderheit in den meisten islamischen
ländern ist das der haltung von etwa 80
prozent der muslime zu glauben dass sie
sich nur um eine kleine minderheit
handele
darum geht es gar nicht wenn die
menschen glauben dass die strafe für den
abfall vom glauben der tod sein sollte
muss ja nicht eine mehrheit auch nach
diesem glauben handeln
aber es gibt die vielleicht schweigende
zustimmung einer großen mehrheit
es mag eine winzige minderheit seien die
gewalt anwendet wenn aber eine große
mehrheit die sie gewalt bin nicht weil
ihr in den moscheen und islamischen
zentren gelehrt wurde das die
todesstrafe für abgefallene richtig sei
dann ist das problem viel größer als
dass es mit unseren konventionen
vereinbar wäre
meine frau unterscheidet da viel besser
es gibt eine kleine minderheit sie so
radikalisiert ist dass sie zur anwendung
von gewalt bereit ist und dann gibt es
eine große mehrheit in der mitte die
will dass der islam eine religion sei
die aber von der unsicherheit geplagt
ist ob die extreme minderheit nicht doch
im recht seien
am anderen rande gibt es eine kleine
minderheit die den islam reformieren
denn den islam reformieren zu wollen ist
gefährlich ich habe heute am wef mit
einem muslim gesprochen der mir gestand
dass sie in seine wirklich nur
ansatzweise abweichenden ansichten in
seinem land der gefahr von attacken
aussetzen würden
unser größtes problem im westen ist dass
wir die reformerischen kräfte nicht
unterstützen wir tun so als ob diese
große mehrheit der gemäßigten mit denen
wir zurechtkommen kein problem sein
oft haben westliche staatsmänner unter
anderem der präsident die usa in die
falle von organisationen ähnlich der
muslimbrüderschaft die behaupten für
eine gemäßigte mehrheit zu sprechen
tatsächlich aber große sympathien für
die extremisten hegen wir nehmen die
reformer nicht zur kenntnis wir schützen
sie nicht und ermutigen sie nicht
es ist wie im kalten krieg als wir den
dissidenten im ostblock einfach
ignorierten
wir haben václav havel ignoriert
walleser solche ziehen
es gibt heute im islam ähnliche
persönlichkeiten die nach reformen rufen
ihnen droht der tod in bangladesch
werden sie gehängt
und was tun wir bieten praktisch nichts
um ihnen zu helfen und sie sagen das
sind die leute die seminar i tät der
reformer mit denen der westen
zusammenspannen müsste und jetzt
springen wir herzhaft 500 600 jahre
zurück weil in ihrem buch die western
rest der westen und der rest der welt
auf deutsch beschreiben sie diese
unwahrscheinliche entwicklung im
experiment der menschheitsgeschichte
dass dieser damals ziemlich bescheidene
die österreich europäische kontinent mit
seinen kleinen staaten und königreichen
das erfolgsmodell wurde der
weltgeschichte und sie möchten dass er
das bleibt springen wir zurück ich weiß
nicht mehr genau wo im buch aber
irgendwo sagen sie wenn wir 1411
hinweisen könnten
und europa und asien vergleichen würden
was würden wir sehen 14 11 in wohin
sollen wir springen
während sie etwa um 1411 auf eine
weltreise gegangen wären sie vielmehr
beeindruckt gewesen von den großen
städten ost oder südasiens als von den
kleinen städten europas
selbst die größte europäische stadt
london oder vielleicht paris war viel
kleiner als etwa nannte die damalige
hauptstadt der ming-dynastie damals im
frühen 15 jahrhundert war der osten dank
einer vielzahl von technischen und
sanitären maßnahmen dem westen überlegen
wir stellen aber fest dass sich nach dem
15 jahrhundert das gleichgewicht
veränderte wir müssen einen räumen der
westen war nicht immer dominant und der
stand der zivilisation im mittelalter
eher bescheiden
deshalb habe ich dieses buch geschrieben
das muss erklärt wäre zu herzogs bleiben
und sie haben die formel eigentlich
gefunden wie der westen sich upgedatet
hat und sie beschreiben das auch mit
sehr schönen modernen metaphern habe ich
sechs killerapplikation hat er
entwickelt wie wie ging das los
es mag eine etwas frivole formel sein
aber ich versuchte das damals nicht nur
meinen studenten zu erklären sondern
auch meinen kindern im teenager alter
das ist eine gewichtige frage warum
stieg der westen praktisch aus dem
nichts zu dieser dominanz zur mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts auf als
westliche imperien die ganze welt
beherrschen
die antwort lässt sich glaube ich am
besten in sechs ideen und institutionen
zusammen fassen und das mein teenagern
verständlich zu machen sagte ich stellt
euch vor ihr nehmt euer smartphone zur
hand und schaut euch die killer apps an
es ist ein wenig wie mit den apps die
sehen einfach aus doch bei näherem
hinsehen entpuppen sie sich als recht
kompliziert nicht viele von uns kennen
den programmiercode der eine app auf dem
smartphone zum laufen bringt die sechs
dinge die auf dem westlichen handy
standen hießen erstens wettbewerb
wirtschaftliche und politische
wettbewerb war legitim
warum bei uns wahrscheinlich zum teil
weil der westen nach dem zerfall des
römischen reiches politisch zersplittert
war im osten war das nicht der fall
sicher nicht in china das bedeutet dass
es de facto eine konkurrenz zwischen
vielen staaten gab
auch zwischen sehr kleinen und innerhalb
dieser staaten waren die monarchen
ziemlich schwach es ist gut in der
schweiz darüber zu sprechen denn die
schweiz ist ein gutes beispiel für die
relative schwäche des zentralstaates sie
sagen wenn das nur auch für viele andere
länder zu treffen
doch im mittelalter waren die meisten
könige schwach und es gab körperschaften
die autonomie genossen etwa im bereich
deshalb
oder die kirche im bereich der religion
usw das heißt es gab keinen
allumfassenden herrscher wie etwa in
china der wie im fünfzehnten jahrhundert
geschehen sagen konnte keine seereisen
mehr keine flotte mehr
das konnte ein kaiser der ming dynastie
sagen nie in der europäischen geschichte
konnte ein kaiser nicht einmal napoleon
auf dem höhepunkt seiner macht den
übersee handel verbieten
europa ist also zu beginn mit einem
scheinbaren nachteil behaftet es ist
zersplittert die könige sind schwach es
gibt zwar immer kleine gebilde wie die
stadt locken die niemand kontrollieren
kann
doch das stellt sich als riesiger
vorteil heraus denn das bedeutet dass
wettbewerb legitim wird und durch
wettbewerb entsteht innovation
wirtschaftlich wie politisch das ist die
killer app nummer eins wie sie sagen
es gilt auch die bedeutung der
wissenschaftlichen revolution zu betonen
das ist etwas völlig neu ist der wandel
in der menschlichen wahrnehmung der
natur
das geschah nirgendwo sonst als im
westen und veränderte unseren begriff
von allen um uns herum und es verstärkte
unsere fähigkeit die natürliche welt zu
manipulieren und zu verändern
killer app nummer zwei ist sehr einfach
wissenschaft die tatsache dass dies im
osmanischen reich nicht geschah das uns
doch viel näher lag als das chinesische
reich ist eigentlich überraschend denn
die ideen der wissenschaftlichen der
revolution ging durch ganz europa wo man
sagt doch die chinesen hätten
wissenschaftliche dinge schießpulver
schon sehr früh beherrscht
[Musik]
sie hatten diese technik aber sie kann
nicht die gesetze der physik
sie hatten keinen juli um sie kamen
nicht über die simple technik des
pulvers hinaus um zu verstehen was
geschieht wenn man ein projektil aus
einer kanone schießt zu berechnen wo
eine granate hinfliegt wenn man sie aus
einem rohr abfeuert dafür braucht es
physik newton und das ist fundamental es
ist eine killer app wenn ihre artillerie
trifft und jeder anderen nicht in diesem
sinne war die physik eine killer app
aber die chinesen in ihren köpfen waren
ja nicht dümmer kontext wo sich kluge
köpfe dann entfalten können und ein
chinesischer newton das gleiche hätte
herausfinden können es gibt eine menge
unterschiede die helfen zu erklären
warum die wissenschaftliche revolution
da stattfand wo sie stattfand
bestimmt ist es kein biologischer auf
die gehirne sind gleich groß die
fähigkeiten sind die gleichen
mein buch ist ein massiver angriff auf
rassische oder kulturelle
erklärungsversuche historischer
veränderungen
es geht um ideen und institutionen die
institution mit den wohl größten
auswirkungen bei einer folge der
reformation in europa nämlich die hohe
alphabetisierungsrate wenn man selber
die bibel lesen kann und das forderten
luther und andere reformatoren dann kann
man alles lesen der bildungsgrad steigt
dramatisch an
mit der ausbreitung der reformation in
den protestantischen ländern
nirgendwo haben sie gesagt die
verbreitung des reformierten
protestantischen glaubens von luther sei
ein ex phänomen gewesen wie heute also
wir seien gar nicht so anders dass die
reformation war das internet der
damaligen zeit
ja gewiss hatte die druckerpresse diese
revolutionäre wirkung und sie
ermöglichte luther seine botschaft mit
unglaublicher geschwindigkeit über
mitteleuropa zu verbreiten kein früherer
häretiker hatte das und ohne
druckerpresse wäre wohl irgendwann auf
dem scheiterhaufen gelandet
das ist entscheidend und es führte auch
zu einer art dominoeffekt
denn das netzwerk ermöglicht eine
wissenschaftliche revolution jeder der
an der natürlichen welt interessiert ist
kann seinen fachkollegen schreiben und
die aufzeichnungen vergleichen und dann
kommt der aufklärung eine weitere
revolution der ideen vor allem in der
philosophie sie vollzieht sich wiederum
über netzwerke
denn alle denken schreiben über
mathematische probleme über
philosophische fragen
da sitzen schotten in edinburgh und
versuchen die grundfragen des seins zu
beantworten und sie tauschen sich aus
mit einem mann in königsberg namens
immanuel kant so geschieht eine lange
reihe von intellektuellen revolutionen
die alle aus einem westlichen netzwerker
vorgehen und außerdem so bald sich auf
der anderen seite des atlantiks eine
bedeutende zahl menschen angesiedelt hat
benjamin franklin fällt mir dabei ein
kann das netzwerk auch den atlantik
überspringen in diesem sinne wird es
nicht nur zu einem europäischen sondern
zu einem klar westlichen phänomen andere
weltgegenden kommen in diesem netzwerk
erst vor wenn sich ausreichend viele
europäer dort niederlassen und dann eben
sagen sie die institutionen rechtsstaat
letztlich der das eigentum garantiert
das natürlich von philosophen wie john
lobb und anderen gefordert wird das ist
bis heute der große unterschiede
rechtsstaatlichkeit garantie von
eigentum
das war auch eine absolut much
entscheidende keller ja ich denke schon
natürlich gibt es die verschiedensten
formen von rechtsstaat
es gibt auch den staat auf basis des
rechts der scharia
doch das ist die falsche art von gesetz
als basis für eine gesellschaft die nach
fortschritt strebt ein grundgesetz das
auf dem recht auf besitz basiert ist der
schlüssel wenn man den menschen das
recht auf privateigentum gibt gibt man
auch anreize zu jeder art von gutem
verhalten zum beispiel den anreiz zur
häufung von kapital
der gesetzliche schutz von eigentum
zusammen mit integren richtern und
unparteiischen gerichten
das war entscheidend das ist meine
dritte killer die vierte ist ganz
einfach medizin
der gewaltige durchbruch der
medizinischen wissenschaften erfolgte
freilich viel später im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
er brachte aber auf einmal eine
verdoppelung der lebenserwartung
es gab eine zeit da hatten nur westliche
menschen eine lebenserwartung von über
50 oder 60 jahren für alle anderen galt
die hälfte das ist das ergebnis einer
markanten medizinischen revolution
bleiben noch zwei weitere killer apps
übrigens es braucht sie alle es klingt
nicht nur eine allein
es braucht auch die konsumgesellschaft
die industrielle revolution ist nutzlos
ohne die konsumgesellschaft
denn die industrielle revolution
bedeutet massenproduktion von kleidern
zu immer tieferen preisen
doch wenn die menschen nicht viele
kleine wollen macht es keinen sinn da
wird der wirtschaftsphilosophie ich ganz
interessant weil ich glaube viele folgen
ihn bei den ersten vier ab cia und dann
kommen wir aber zu den helden in
schottland die ganz kluge dinge heraus
gefordert haben also ihre
intellektuellen helden wenn es schon
competition gibt sagt adam smith der
vater der liberalen wirtschafts wesens
dann soll man das spielen lassen und die
unsichtbare hand schaut dafür dass das
im interesse der gesellschaft ist das
hat die konsums die leute die das kaufen
können die arbeiter die löhne haben da
erfolgen ihnen jetzt nicht mehr alle
weil sie sagen marx hat gezeigt und sie
denken das gilt bis heute
es ist eben nicht so dass alle die
gleichen chancen haben im feld der
wirtschaft der arbeiter ist abhängig vom
besitzer der produktionsmittel und viele
würden ihn sogar sagen okay schön und
gut competition wettbewerber anfangen
daraus ist ein raubtier kapitalismus
geworden wo ein paar ganz reich werden
und viele immer ärmer und der gab die
schere wird immer größer so toll ist der
kapitalismus dann doch nicht es gibt ein
großes problem mit dem argument dass sie
soeben vorgebracht haben aber bevor wir
weiter gehen lohnt es sich anzumerken
dass auch die idee von marx eine
westliche idee ist
sie kam ihm zuerst im rheinland und dann
in london wo er die meiste zeit seines
lebens verbrachte eine ironie der
geschichte ist dass es da ein disput
zwischen mehreren westlichen ideen gab
die liberale idee der marktwirtschaft
von adams mef gegen die forderung von
marx nachkontrolle der produktionsmittel
und damit verhinderung des privaten
eigentums bei dieses zu immer größere
ungleichheit führte warum war dies
falsch weil schon bald nachdem marx das
kapital geschrieben hatte
sich de facto die ungleichheit
verminderte die löhne stiegen und zwar
am schnellsten in den industrieländern
wie großbritannien sehr schnell auch in
den usa als dort die industrialisierung
einsetzte und ob schon einzelne große
vermögen machten stieg der
lebensstandard der arbeiterklasse und da
liegt das problem denn marx hatte
vorausgesagt dass er sinken würde
das ist unbestreitbar die fakten
sprechen für sie könnte es nicht sein
dass das wieder dreht man hat hier viel
im forum von der vierten industriellen
revolution gesprochen oder die roboter
kommen dann haben wir vielleicht keine
arbeit mehr und vielleicht ist das
problem der verarmung der arbeitenden
klasse dann zurück wo sie das werden wir
ja sehen lassen oder auch vorhergesagt
im neunzehnten jahrhundert als die
textilproduktion mechanisiert und die
hand lieber arbeitslos wurde es würde
eine katastrophe geben hieß es
aber es wurden viel mehr arbeitsplätze
geschaffen dank dieser innovationen
ich glaube es ist zu früh den schluss zu
ziehen dass die roboter uns alle
arbeitslos machen wäre diese
kassandrarufe haben ja auch früher schon
gehört und sie waren falsch vergessen
wir nicht während wir hier sprechen
vermindert sich die ungleichheit in der
welt trotz allem was thomas pitti und
andere prophezeien
der weltweite trend zeigt eine abnahme
der ungleichheit weil immer mehr
menschen der armut auf dem land
entfliehen und einen lohn arbeit
annehmen
marx these kann kein comeback feiern
solange das so ist
ruft mich an wenn die globale
ungleichheit steigt ich werde darauf
zurückkommen
ich glaube oxfam die organisation wird
sie vielleicht bald anrufen die haben
vor zwei drei tagen doch zahlen
publiziert die das sowie das wollten wir
nicht in einer philosophie sendung hier
statistisch aus diskutieren ich verstehe
natürlich die statistik ist irre führen
sie müssen zugeben wenn sie vor 30
jahren entsprechende berechnungen
gemacht hätten wäre schlimmer gewesen
und wenn sie heute die liste der reichen
ansehen sind es zu einem beträchtlichen
teil keine leute aus dem westen
eine ansehnliche zahl in dieser winzigen
elite von kapitalisten sind chinesen
tatsächlich gibt es in der freien
wettbewerbs gesellschaft die im westen
entstanden ist eine gewisse ungleichheit
denn die menschen sind leider nicht
gleich geschaffen worden
sie wurden vielmehr geschaffen mit einer
sehr ungleiche verteilung der
eigenschaften den menschen auf der einen
seite der verteilung geht es tendenziell
ungleich viel besser weil sie ungleich
viel schlauer sind als der durchschnitt
und sie werden dafür sorgen dass auch
ihre kinder über dem durchschnitt liegen
wir müssen einfach zugeben dass eine
gewisse ungleichheit zum wesen einer
freien gesellschaft gehört marx hat
darauf bestanden dass die ungleichheit
immer schlimmer werde bis zum
zusammenbruch der ganzen gesellschaft in
einer revolutionären krise er lag falsch
das traf höchstens in einer völlig
zurückgebliebenen gesellschaft zu in
russland und später china wo die
industrialisierung nicht weit
fortgeschritten war
mit marx abzuschließen ein westliches
gehirn da haben sie recht kann man in
einem satz sagen er hat die geschichte
verändert ganz gewiss seine idee ist so
potent vom späten 19
bis ins 20 jahrhundert wie glaube ich
der radikale islam in unserer zeit sein
wird eine idee das ist auch der inhalt
meines buches kann die welt verändern
wenn sie sich wie ein virus verbreitet
das bringt mich zum letzten thema das
ich mit ihnen hier besprechen möchte und
kann in der zeit die wir haben
machen die individuen geschichte und
marx wäre jetzt ein beispiel mit seinen
ideen und man kann sagen sie haben viel
von ihrer großen energie als historiker
in den letzten zehn jahren diese man
hier gewinnt wird henry kissingers für
viele der inbegriff des politischen
realismus alles andere sagen tunis wo
sondern unter richard nixon hatte er
diese politik gemacht die sich nicht
kümmert
die folgen eine unmoralische politik
wurde angeklagt von seinem kritikern es
gibt leute die sagen ein völkermord
nein sie haben viele jahre investiert um
ihn zu verstehen
der erste band ist draußen ich fand
witzig als ich erst nachdem ich das
gelesen habe
gesehen habe er erster titel entwurf war
der amerikanische machiavelli zuerst
haben sie ihn auch werden machiavelli
das war noch vor meinen recherchen als
ich mir überlegte wie ich das thema
angehen sollte die meisten menschen
denken und kissinger sein erz
realistischer machiavelli oder bismarck
ist und ich dachte das wohl auch als ich
mich bereit erklärt das buch zu
schreiben
sagen sie uns noch wie es dazu kam er
hat sie angefragt
ihr seid ja es war seine idee ich glaube
übrigens nicht dass er mich aber als
erster an fragte aber ich war der
welcher zusagte ich zögerte teilweise
aus den gründen die sie angesprochen
haben
er ist eine überaus widersprüchliche
persönlichkeit und ich rechnete mit
feindseligen kommentaren von seiten
gewisser kritiker nur schon über die
tatsache dass überhaupt über henry
kissinger eine biografie geschrieben
wird andererseits schien mir nachdem ich
einsicht in seine privaten
aufzeichnungen die wichtigste quelle zu
diesem buch genommen hatte dass dies
eine geschichte von enormer bedeutung
war persönlich wir sind uns zufällig bei
einem gesellschaftlichen anlass in
london begegnet vor über einem dutzend
jahren
wir sprachen über ein buch das sich über
den ersten weltkrieg geschrieben habe
man muss bedenken dass kinder seine
laufbahn als historiker begann und zum
teil auch als geschichte
er hatte ihr buch gelesen
ja und wir sprachen darüber das war der
anfang unserer beziehung
man muss zugeben ob man ihn liebt oder
hasst dass er eine bedeutende
persönlichkeit ist während seinen 93
lebensjahren sind erstaunliche
entwicklungen geschehen um nur die
amerikanische öffnung gegenüber china zu
nennen
das war wohl das hervorstechendste
ereignis während des kalten krieges mit
so dramatischen wirtschaftlichen folgen
dass man sich kaum mehr vorstellen kann
wie china noch 1971 ausgesehen hat ja
denn er reist der 1971 in geheimer
mission nach china und die gespräche
resultierten darin dass nixon 1972 nach
china reiste das ist ein historisch
äußerst wichtiges ereignis und es schien
mir wichtig nehmen wir den man in
erfahrung zu bringen der diesen großen
strategischen durchbruch bewerkstelligte
das ist schon für sich allein gesehen
eine großartige geschichte
er war ein flüchtling wir haben hier
unser gespräch über flüchtlinge begonnen
henry kissinger kam 1939 als flüchtlinge
aus deutschland in die usa
er war soldat er war agent in der
spionageabwehr nazi-jäger historiker
philosoph ein intellektueller die erste
hälfte seines lebens von dir dieses buch
handelt ist eine bemerkenswerte und
weitgehend unbekannte geschichte die uns
unter anderem sehr viel über die zeit
des kalten krieges erzählt ist das
selten dass einer wie sie schreiben ein
genie in der historischen analyse ist
und in der praktischen politik meine
richard nixons mann fürs grobe in der
außenpolitik zu sein das ist eine heiße
küche also als er war ein politisches
naturtalent und ein guter denkt er war
zuerst ein akademiker und hat sich erst
nach und nach politisch profilieren
er studierte in harvard
er kam zurück aus dem besetzen
deutschland nachdem er dort seiner
dienstpflicht beendet hatte und ging zur
universität wie viele andere just von
haar wird auswahl mit glanz abschluss
begann er seine akademische karriere mit
einem lehrauftrag im government
das besondere an seiner karriere war
dass er eine bemerkenswerte figur des
öffentlichen lebens wurde als
intellektueller dessen bücher auch
außerhalb
akademische kreise gelesen wurden der im
fernsehen auftrat und der für die
zeitschrift foreign affairs und für
zeitungen schrieb er wurde ein
einflussreicher vordenker der
amerikanischen außenpolitik
so erstaunt es nicht dass sie nächsten
1968 zu seinem sicherheitsberater
beriefen erstaunlich hingegen war das
kissinger über die ganze zeit von der
dieses buch handelt nächsten feindlich
gesinnt war er war berater von nelson
rockefeller gewesen
nächstens erzfeind innerhalb der
republikanischen partei wiederum vor 67
hatten sie sozusagen kein kontakt
das ist dann ein thema für den zweiten
band und ich bin ist etwa bei zwei
drittel meiner recherchen
darum möchte ich lieber nicht auf diese
frage antworten ich bin noch nicht ganz
sicher großen weltpolitischen mechaniker
zum schluss ist das was verlockendes für
1 hj professor von heute würden sie
gerne nicht nur beraten sondern im
vorzimmer von obama aber in seinem
außenministerium sitzen und sagen das
machen wir jetzt mal so ich wäre im
bereich der politik bestimmt viel
weniger begabt als henry kissinger war
und ich habe auch keinerlei ambitionen
ich habe eben meinen früheren hubert
kollegen eskorte zur zeit
verteidigungsminister über das sprechen
gehört was ihn am meisten beunruhigt die
verantwortung die er als
verteidigungsminister trägt ist eher
abschreckend und unterm strich ist es
mir lieber bücher zu schreiben und im
bereich der macht anders überlassen wir
haben gesagt sie sind hierher gekommen
aber so ein berühmter historiker aber
einer der eben über praktika aktuelle
themen analysen abgibt und ratschläge
gibt ihr idol henry kissinger ich glaube
das letzte große hochwasser geschrieben
habe das world oder die neue weltordnung
und bleibt eine minute in einer minute
wie kann
was ist die neue weltordnung die diese
welt anstreben sollte nur förster ich
möchte betonen er ist nicht mein idol
man sollte das objekt an der biografie
nicht zum idol zurück
man sollte das objekt einer biografie
verstehen eine weltordnung gibt es nicht
wir leben in einer welt in unordnung
es gab eine weltordnung im gefolge des
zweiten weltkriegs die während des
kalten krieges vorherrschte diese
weltordnung in welcher den usa
dominierten befindet sich im zustand der
auflösung teilweise wegen ökonomischer
verschiebungen auf der welt teilweise
wegen demografische verschiebungen teils
auch wegen der zunehmenden
absonderlichkeiten der amerikanischen
innenpolitik
sonst hält man ausschau nach einer
ordnung
kissinger findet es gebe mindestens vier
vorstellungen von einer welt aus
eine amerikanische eine europäische eine
chinesische und eine islamische jetzt
nur noch 30 sekunden zeigt was ich das
wichtigste was muss man tun ob wir ja
eindeutig beste ausgang aus meiner sicht
ist wenn die westliche zivilisation
überlebt und vorherrscht ich will nicht
in einer chinesisch oder islamisch
beherrschten welt leben denn wir würden
unsere freiheit für die freiheiten
welche den kern der westlichen kultur
ausmachen sind es wert geschätzt werden
wir im westen müssen alles tun um unsere
zivilisation zu schützen und sie vor
rückfällen zu bewahren
ökonomisch technisch kulturell und
strategisch das kann man tun wenn man
reagiert richtig agiert jetzt absolut
ganz bestimmt nie vergessen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch herr
thies davon danke ja von der geschichte
der menschheit haben wir geredet in der
sternstunde kunst geht es gleich wieder
um die geschichte eines einzelnen
menschen
peter liechti einer der ungewöhnlichsten
und wichtigsten filmemacher der schweiz
verstarb im frühling 2014 dedication
sein letztes unvollendet gebliebenes
werk vorher aber noch ein
gedankenexperiment aus unserer kleinen
serie heute zur frage was schulden wir
menschen in not
[Musik]